[Musique]
daniel tammet tu a récité la première
décimale de pi a récité les décimales de
pi les 200000 514e premières décimales
de pi pendant six heures de mémoire je
n'y suis pas arrivé jozef chovanec parle
une dizaine de langues qui l'a parfois
apprirent peut-être en une semaine ce
qui lui permet de parcourir le monde
en abolissant les frontières ça non plus
je n'y suis pas arrivé tle grand deane a
mis au point un système révolutionnaire
pour dans le traitement du bétail qui a
révolutionné toutes les exploitations
d'élevage américaines qui l'ont adopté
environ à 50 % ça même en concentrant
très fort ça non plus je n'y serais pas
arrivé
cependant un point commun nous rully me
relis à ces trois personnes à ces trois
personnalités
je suis autistes alors on aime bien dans
la famille l'autiste souvent on entend
une frontière imaginaire entre autiste
de haut niveau est autiste de bas niveau
à votre avis on me range dans quelle
catégorie vous allez sans doute dire
autiste de haut niveau peut-être mais si
vous m'aviez rencontrés durant mon
enfance
vous auriez sans doute une réponse tout
à fait différente
en effet je ne n'ai pas parlé jusqu'à
l'âge de 6 ans et tant et si bien que
cela m'a causé beaucoup de soucis à
l'école que dès l'âge de deux ans on ma
destinée un aller simple en hôpital
psychiatrique
heureusement auxquels j'ai pu échapper
j'avais beau savoir lire et écrire et
compter avant de savoir parler ça
n'empêchait pas les professeurs qui
accepter malgré eux à l'école de
m'appeler affectueusement le cerveau
lent donc finalement fendick de moi que
je suis un autiste de haut niveau depuis
que j'ai écrit un livre
depuis que j'ai écrit un des célèbres
l'autisme l'autisme a souvent été
assimilée à une psychose
aujourd'hui 60 % des séjours longs en
hôpital psychiatrique en france sont le
fait d' autiste je vous assure qu'il ya
certains matins où je me regarde dans la
glace et je me dis ouf je ne suis pas
une statistique les autistes souvent
envoyé vont être souvent cachés derrière
les murs gavé de neuroleptiques vous
entendrez souvent dans les médias des
discours entendant éradiquer le fléau de
l'autisme éradiquer l'autisme l'autisme
se caractérise notamment par on va dire
une forme de déficiences sociales qui va
souvent elle va être interprété à tort
comme de la déficience mentale
alors qu'il va s'agir une déficience
mentale apparente mais en effet dans un
monde basé sur le verbe la communication
et l'image l'autisme va souvent être
assimilés est vécue comme un handicap le
handicap
il convient de se poser la question si
ce n'est pas plutôt la société qui s'en
dit qu'apple même en excluant de
nombreuses minorités au diversité
fonctionnelle ou des profil cognitif
particulier finalement n'est ce pas la
société elle-même qui se met en
situation de handicap en se privant de
compétences et de potentiel qu'elle va
méprisé par exemple si un bâtiment est
inaccessible pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
et bien vous allez voir que dans ce
bâtiment beaucoup d'autres populations
bien au delà ces minorités rencontreront
des problèmes et ça pourra même parfois
être extrêmement dangereux donc le
handicap n'est pas une affaire de
minorité le handicap et la sphère de
l'humanité entière en france pendant que
le monde entier en particulier par
exemple l'italie ou en les pays en
europe du nord ont fait le pari de
l'inclusion
c'est à dire d'ouvrir le milieu
ordinaire à commencer par l'école à
toutes les neuro diversité à toutes les
diversités fonctionnel quelle qu'elle
soit en france nous vivons dans le pays
le plus institutionnalisé au niveau de
toutes les différences par exemple
pendant qu'en italie 100 % des enfants
qui sont scolarisés en france 80% des
enfants autistes sont déscolarisés 90%
de la population autistes en france est
au chômage
l'autisme est en perpétuelle
augmentation en parlait d'une naissance
sur cent il ya encore dix ans il ya cinq
ans on parlait d'une naissance sur 50
une étude américaine pointe une
naissance sur 68 une étude récente
sud-coréenne pointe même une naissance
sur 38 l'autisme est en perpétuelle
augmentation
certains scientifiques chercheurs ont
décidé de se poser sur la question avec
un autre paradigme et si il s'agissait
devant l'ampleur de ce phénomène
évidemment s'il ne s'agissait pas là
d'une autre intelligence en effet
l'autisme va se caractériser par un
profil cognitif particulier c'est à dire
que certes il va avoir des déficiences
sociales mais souvent chez les sujets y
compris les sujets non verbaux la
mémoire visuelle va être plus développée
la mémoire auditive va des fois être
beaucoup plus grande beaucoup auront
l'oreille absolue et se profile ce
profil d'une autre intelligence ses
compétences particulières qui se vont
s'avérer souvent supérieurs à la moyenne
c'est vrai qu'il s'avère que souvent
contrairement à ce qu'on croit ce ne
sont pas forcément les autistes verbaux
qui vont des fois être les plus
performants dans certains domaines et
l'intelligence autistique commence à
intéresser par exemple certains
gouvernements
c'est le cas de du ministère de la
défense d'israël
il ya quelques années ils ont mis sur
pied un projet qui consistait à engager
des autistes à les incorporer dans des
unités
l'it pour des départements d'analysé de
photos aériennes
ce programme s'est avéré être un succès
et donc ce programme qui s'intitule voir
loin aujourd'hui l'armée israélienne
pour rien au monde ne voudraient se
passer de cet atout de l'intelligence
autistique en grande bretagne au royaume
uni une statistique très intéressante
est sorti il ya peu de temps
saviez vous que en grande bretagne 4 %
de la population est dyslexique
or il s'avère que parmi la population
des chefs et des créateurs d'entreprise
les dyslexiques sont représentés à
hauteur de 20%
donc là on peut se poser la question de
la tipp isme c'est à dire que les
dyslexiques également vont avoir
beaucoup de problèmes en général
d'exclusion mais il s'avère que se
priver finalement des spécificités peut
pourrait finalement s'avérer assez
fatale la silicon valley a été bâti par
les profils atypiques l'informatique a
été créée par les autistes pour les
autistes 10 à bill gates
ce n'est plus un scoop lui aussi fait
partie de notre club
saviez vous que microsoft organise
chaque année un recrutement spécialisé
réservé pour les personnes autistes pour
développer certains programmes
informatiques
il ya même des personnes qui trichent
sur leur cv en se faisant passer pour
autistes pour avoir le job
on a du mal à imaginer ça en france ou
lorsque vous êtes dans le spectre
autistique dans le spectre le spectre de
l'autisme vous avez plutôt intérêt à le
cacher pour ne serait-ce qu avoir une
chance d'être scolarisés et ensuite
avoir un travail
or aujourd'hui il ya des sociétés qui
compterait même de 80% d'autistes dans
leur effectif
savez vous pourquoi la couleur du
premier réseau social et bleu parce que
le bleu est la couleur symbole de
l'autisme et son inventeur en bois
notice tu avais des problèmes de
communication dans tout ce qui était de
l'ordre des contextes sociaux il a donc
inventé le premier réseau social qui
consiste à pouvoir se connecter avec
n'importe qui dans le monde sans être
obliger de
passé par les situations où les autistes
rond source justement se retrouvent en
situation de handicap
et c'est ainsi que les inventions des
atypiques finalement profite à tout le
monde
l'intelligence autistique est même
devenu un marché aujourd'hui vous avez
des compagnies spécialisées dans le
recrutement de profils atypiques
aujourd'hui la valeur artistique est en
train de devenir la valeur montante est
le placement le plus sûr pour de
nombreuses entreprises en france nous
avons malheureusement tendance à
édulcorer cette question alors que au
niveau international le monde est en
train de se mettre en marche pour ce
genre de ce genre de spécificité c'est à
dire mettra en avant la différence
la population autistes et souvent
appréhendé pour ses défauts vous
entendrez souvent dans la bouche des
politiques que le terme autisme dans le
monde médiatico-politique et top à peu
près à la première place soult dans la
cour de récréation pour comme une
insulte et l'insulté suprême pour nady
dénigrer ou moqués son adversaire et si
au lieu de parc et la différence de
créer une société ghettoïsant tu nous
intéressions au potentiel de quelque
chose qui au lieu d'être appréhendé un
par un comme un défaut si nous
commencions appréhender l'autisme pour
ses qualités je pense que c'est l'avenir
nous sommes à l'aube d'une révolution
le spectre d'une ère nouvelle s'annonce
et les acteurs de cette révolution
savent qu'une société basée sur des
contraintes de normalité finira
inévitablement par s'étouffer dans les
normes qu'elle se sera elle même créé
mais les acteurs de cette révolution
savent aussi que le pari de l'avenir est
le pari de l'atypisme et de la diversité
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]